so what do you do what do I do my name
is Scott and I own a male strip club hi
guys so we have a really big live show
coming up so we want to do something
really memorable and incredible you want
to I'm gonna get some [ __ ] wet I
think exactly what I yeah I can help you
with that if you if you're willing to
commit to it when women go out to a male
strip show they're very open with each
other about their fantasies may they
expect to be entertained so you have to
do a lot more than just take off your
clothes it's more like theater exactly
yeah girls don't really appreciate that
as much as they do the entire
performance really portraying a
character from A to Z with visuals and
costumes and the theme and the look
Hollywood man is a collection of the
most popular female sexual fantasies
brought to life on stage we have a group
number mm-hm that you'll be teaching us
choreography - how many weeks do you
have to prepare okay we better get
started rolling that body into your
crotch it's not you can't just say just
body boy boy as long as you don't mind
me being brutally honest I'm not gonna
waste your time don't waste money I
don't promise that we won't waste a
little bit of your time the most
important thing would be stage presence
if you can smile on stage and carry a
crowd without necessarily having to do
it with your body it's tough to get out
of your head and forget your
choreography and just have the eye
contact with the crowd and have that
stage presence do we need names like
stripper names oh yeah yeah are there
stripper names Emmer's burgers today
classic these are ladies they loosen
them up get them to laugh I'm a
Bachelorette I'm about to get wet you're
like beat sexy than Allison you're like
oh you downplay the sexiness okay so you
almost get sexy but then not this is
downplaying sexy
so here's like a coy little me I'm just
like a willy wonka the only thing that's
it's not what you expect that's what I
try to put onstage ripping off pants is
hard what's harder than that ripping off
a straitjacket nasty dead I went to a
mental institution because I just had
boners all the time
velcro goes down the sides it's like
when you're about to it a woman's
panties off I'm dialed in how do I make
that sexy zest easy just easy it's like
a lemon rind on your body or what I am a
defender of the universe Oh super hero
Star Wars I have a lightsaber oh dude
when you got the button to come on you
gotta go you could just hold it here and
just look at the girls with your
eyebrows up and they get the point we
use a lot of audience members in the
routine grab a girl out of the audience
lay her down and then for the great
finale she strokes your lightsaber when
women get in this environment it's so
electric it's like we're a catalyst in a
test-tube of women you come backstage
with scratches down your back and I've
given lap dances drunk we gotta use a
girl that's gonna do what you want and
not do what you don't want
I've never had someone tell me like this
is a great lap dance move on the dagger
yes the hiring standards are very strict
I'll put it that way all right let's see
what you guys can do without it
let's see if you're ready and remember
be sexy six how's it going ladies enjoy
for coming out tonight
welcome to P live we're gonna get weird
and they're about to get a lot weirder
so this is it we're here it's the night
of the live show apparently there is a
line around the block nervous but yeah
I'm terrified it's really uncomfortable
putting yourself out there like this
we've never performed anything like this
in front of strangers I I just did the
tech run through a lot of stuff went
wrong when I did the rehearsal the pants
didn't fully rip off I focus so much on
choreography that when I forgot
something I just got mad and I stopped
you know what though I feel good I have
a lot of nervous energy right now well
if you just relax
hump some girl face and I get to do it
with you know the rest of the try guys
and we all are bringing a different
thing to the table I'm just gonna go out
there and feed off that energy of the
crowd all right you ready to horse out
hopefully will make the Hollywood men
proud
[Applause]
[Applause]
it's definite you could barely hear the
news of your dancing for me it was crazy
because I didn't see the audience until
I took my horse mask off and by then
there was just there was just a sea of
cell phone cameras it was like I was
like Miley Cyrus I stuffed my thong
sweet'n low and just showered it all
over the audience the sweet and low is
fly-in people were screaming but
thrusting like dick that way in that way
this is the greatest day of my life the
crowd was so energetic they were so into
it and I just fed off of that and like
unleash my inner freak show it was
amazing I tease them slowly and then
[Music]
nailed and that was the greatest feeling
in the world
[Music]
[Applause]
that was the most fun I've ever had I
just felt these importantly in control
the thrill of ripping your underwear off
in front of over a hundred people oh my
god it's the biggest thrill I've ever
had in my life
I do wish you chosen someone other than
my girlfriend to dance on
[Applause]
you see had a great time she was
showering buddy on you huh once that got
out of my own head and got more into my
pelvis veins works beautifully you know
what it all just washed when right I
just performed and I connected with the
audience I have black danced the [ __ ]
out of Ned's wife the pinnacle of rude
things you can do to a person I gave her
a good left I want to do it again I
would do this all the time I think the
key to life now is just got a strip
sometimes that's the secret you just
take off all your clothes everybody
loves you but it's more about putting on
a great show and we put on a pretty good
[Music]
[Applause]
give it up for the try guys ladies and
gentlemen give it up I live in the world
and we get to get naked in front of
complete strangers and they scream but
in a good way